[Applaus]
[Musik]
für die Reportage treffe ich trübbar wo
hier zum Kleid ewiger Liebi und alte
Traditionen
bei 40.000 findet
und ich freue mich mega fest das wird
sicher das mega schön allgemein
von Partner an und ich frag mich ob man
in dem Moment nicht
Identität aufgeht
ich bin der Simon sehr sehr konkret sie
hören und sie nimmt auch der Name auf
ihrem zukünftigen Mann vom René
simon hat Plan wir bringen Deko zu der
Hochzeitslocation wo nur das paar
Minuten entfernt im gleichen Dorf liegt
und wie ist das bis jetzt schon nervös
Empfang
ich 48 Stunden eigentlich
richtig zu meiner Familie
und
falls es irgendwann
möchtest Familie
Identität dass ich heute fast 30 Jahre
mit dem klappt und ich kann ich
publizieren unter dem Namen ich habe
studiert mit dem name
umso wichtiger sie hatte unbedingt weil
er palte und so es Stück für ihre
Identität Welle bewahren jetzt aber Zeit
zum mit dem Rene es neues Kapitel Arzt
fangen
bei den Ringe
aber
schöne daran ist
jetzt gut
und das ist im Alltag auch gut
funktioniert haben mit dem Zimmer
Wohnung und alles und dass man trotzdem
noch mega happy sind und keine
Langeweile
mache ein Foto mit der ältesten Person
mach ein Foto mit der Braut jetzt
langweilig
und realistisch zugleich
weil romantisch
obwohl es vielleicht finanziell nicht
und seit morgen machen und realistisch
denn so dass man seit man muss nur
glücklich ist müssen
findet hoffentlich nicht entscheidend
aber ja er hätte realistisch
romantisch und realistisch gleichzeitig
es leuchtet mir nie was dir zwei sagen
und mir ist bewusst dass viele Menschen
in erster Linie aus
aber ich bin es einiges Kind und tragen
für dich halt darum mit mir ein gewisser
Pessimismus
werdet in der Schweiz geschieden und
trotzdem liegt hyrate nach wie vor im
Trend im letzten Jahr hat sich 40.000
[Musik]
für Ihre Hochzeit und das ist ihre
zukünftige Frau Jenny die zwei Männer
sind sie standesamtlich verheiratet
haben aber
Familie dass das sicher funktioniert
ihre Kollegin Milena ist schon
verheiratet mit dem Vorsprung quasi sich
vorstellen was sich in der Beziehung vor
der Jenny und der ringkuchen die
verändere also für mich hat sich schon
so angefühlt als hätte sich dadurch auch
einiges geändert das ist klar wir haben
sind Schritt weiter gegangen es wurde
ernster
wenn man aus der ganzen Geschichte
wieder raus will dann ist eine Hürde
mehr da aber eigentlich
[Musik]
schon gutes Paar
trinke und Jenny Ernst merkt dass das
zwischen ihnen passt der attrakt sie
sich letztjahr nachdem sie es halbes
Jahr zusammen gemacht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ganz schöne Frisur was du immer machen
wirst und das Match mit deiner mit
deinem Termin total gut aus
[Musik]
Jenny und Trinken
Alltag
zusammenzubringen also ich hätte jetzt
zu Zeit was heißt knirke oder lange ich
glaube es wird theoretisch so lange
grundlegend irgendwie speziell oder
andere Sachen wo ich mir so wichtig sind
[Musik]
wir auch schön zum dass wir sagen machen
politische Akten
dass du das Recht aber nimmst hast
[Musik]
ja
ich finde es tut schon
das Avent denn
nachvollziehen und ich merke dass ich
mich gar nicht am heiraten Liebe also
das zwei Menschen ihre Liebe eventiere
sondern erwartet wo nicht dahinter
gespüre wer heiratet der hat's geschafft
wer nicht
Angst der oder die richtig noch nicht
gefunden oder ist romantisch
auch bis vor einer erwartet wird bis
Tradition so will man gern eure Gedanken
dazu entkommen
kommt gut
so wenn ihr say the setamin Starts wie
kommt das ist ihre Priester mit ihm
besprechen Sie der Ablauf von der
Trauung
[Musik]
der Rudi und Cassandra sind beide
katholisch aufgewachsen
[Musik]
okay Android
gibt
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
eine ganz privat im Moment
vor ihrem Vater und Alltag geführt und
in Ruhe die übergehen und sie wird es
weißes Kleid tragen er Tradition wo
Dreiheit vor der Frau symbolisiert die
klassische Geschlechterrolle von MA und
Frau sie werden zugspitzter dem Tag ich
fragte beide entwickeln
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
und jetzt geht es natürlich zwei Arten
entweder
und Hydrate das
Gott immer das wird mir
gefallen und
dass sie sich
vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt
eine Gesellschaft oder eine Teil von der
Gesellschaft Arbeit
so stark möchte
auf die romantische Liebe konzentrieren
und auf
das
aber ich freue mich
ob das Konstrukte
zurück bitte Jenny und der Rinko sie
suchen für Ihre Hochzeit aus also ich
glaube am Anfang zum Anschluss
und nachher haben eigentlich gesagt dass
man wir noch Hibiskus
spritzenkarte
gibt's für sie überhaupt genug Platz in
dem traditionellen Konstrukte mit der
Hochzeitsvorbereitungen
also wir haben im Schloss Haltung und
nachher ist trotzdem
nach oben also
dass du gerade Fußball
und bin auf die Option Noni also zum
Beispiel
aber es gibt klar
und ich weiß nicht für mich ist einfach
eher so ein Thema
bewusst machen
ich würde das einfach so auf der ganzen
Welt eigentlich immer mega Lust nach
oben geht also wirklich das Gefühl
wichtiger Schritt machen
so ein momentan
ist Gedächtnis holt will man halt ja
keine Ahnung
ja nicht einfach Frauen
okay ich kann nicht
[Musik]
fast Jenny da seid ist für mich ein
Reality-Check ich mache Reportage
darüber wieso man im Jahr 2023 überhaupt
nur hyrotet der B ist es gar nicht für
alle Menschen möglich bzw
Identität und zu sein
umso entspannter
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zwischen Traditionen erwartige von der
Gesellschaft und den Wunsch
sind komplex und Nummer auch
mich dann wieder ganz einfach Liebe
zwischen zwei Personen ist gesund Tricks
und ich verstehe dass mir die Wort viere
ich bleibe vorerst mal auf der Seite
aber hat mich hochzeitskleber jetzt doch
verwünscht und ich sind es immer und
statt dass mir also Jahre immer alleine
führt wenn man das entschieden zum der
das hier mit Freunde
zum anderen
Kollegen der Viktoria die überreportage